>> In terms of your work at Facebook, what
are some recent projects that you've been working on?
>> So, one thing I'm really fascinated by is how information flows
through networks. So, in my early work, this was just how webpages linked
together. But, with online social networks
being such a prevalent means of communicating
these days there's a lot of transmission from individual to individual or from
individual to their social network. And, there
are these things called memes which are ideas
that seemed to almost take advantage of this
to replicate themselves. So, some Facebook status updates,
for example, will have a little piece of text that says copy and paste or repost
or post this so that all your friends will see if you agree with this statement.
One interesting thing about memes is that they tend
to recur over time. So, sometimes you see a meme
and it's like oh, yeah, I saw that one a
year ago and now it's back and how does it
come back? So, we looked at one particular meme. This
is the Moneybags meme, which says that you know, this
year, October has five Fridays, Saturdays, Sundays. This happens only
once every 823 years and this is a lucky occurrence,
blah, blah, blah and anyone who actually looks it up,
sees that this kind of occurrence is much more frequent
and in fact, you'll have different variants of the meme.
For example, here in red, you have the one that says,
July has five Fridays, Saturdays, Sundays. And this is true
in 2011 and if you just look at this plot, which
will, on a linear scale, show you the counts for
this meme, it may appear as though it just disappears completely
in between. So, you might think, well, maybe it's
being introduced from some other source and not Facebook.
But the weird thing is that the meme is
adapted to Facebook. It says, copy and paste, which doesn't
make so much sense for other media. So, is
it possible that the meme is actually staying within
Facebook but in very low numbers, and then flares
up? And so if you, instead of using a linear
scale, use a log scale here at the
same time, you can see counts that are 100,000
and counts that are 10. And so here when
you look, you can see that even though there's
a rapid decay in interest, it actually looks
like it's maybe parallel and you can see the
meme persisting in low numbers. And then different variants,
perhaps being prompted by a resurgence of this meme,
then subsequently occurring. These were done in ggplot, just with
a simple line geome and grouping by the particular meme
variant and then rescaling the ax, the y-axis to log in one of the versions.